Norma is with us to start off this hour
in Greensboro North Carolina I Norma how
are you hi Dave thanks so much for
taking my call I really appreciate it my
pleasure how can I help yes so my
parents and I are really trying to
figure out on how to or what to do with
this parent plus loan they took out for
me over 12 years ago of course had I
known then what I know now things would
look totally different but the loan is
now at 72 thousand dollars my parents
are no way able to pay for this my dad
was supposed to retire in September
we're all freaking out because we're
worried they're gonna garnish his check
where's my husband are trying to figure
out what we need to do to pay this off
whether we need to sell our house or
take out we don't know what to do we're
all kind of panicking I feel burdened by
this because this is their only debt and
it's really holding them back and so I
just I just need guidance I'm willing to
do whatever we need to do to free them
of this why have they not paid it off
I'm their own financial crisis my dad
only makes about $1,800 a month or the
loan or the payment is like out $1,000
right now they live in their green
borrow seventy two thousand dollars if
he makes $1,800 a month well this was
12th at 12 years ago and at that and
then it was not at 72 thousand dollars
with the interest and then not being
able to pay that is where it is now my
dad yes what was original I believe it
should have been about 40,000 so your
dad forgot $40,000 loan he made $20,000
a year no at that time he was in
California he made significantly more on
the job closed so it was kind of like a
just a crisis after crisis and it was
they had already taken out that loan
holder you you know I am 31
what's your household income so our
household is about anywhere from 3,000
to about 7,000 just as in the last two
to three months my husband just left his
job
we're both working our own businesses
are doing setters and it was Prior so
we're hoping to be able to take care of
some things a dad knew you have we have
my husband's a student loan at 39,000
and then our mortgage at 108 thousand we
have about sixty thousand and equity in
our house mm-hmm
well the your parents are the only ones
that are liable for this loan legally
you know that right mm-hmm
okay morally you want to help your
parents because they have made a mess
and they did that to help you yes and so
you feel the moral obligation although
at the time they took out the loan you
guys did not even have a handshake that
said you are responsible for this they
fully intended to pay for it they just
never have right and they still feel
like they want to handle it but they're
they know they can't and I know they
can't right what's their house worth
they don't have any we live in an
apartment so they don't have any debt
outside of my student loan they don't
own the house okay and how old are they
my dad's gonna be 65 in September and my
mom is like what is your mom not work
she's had some medical challenges that
have prevented her from working what are
the nature of her medical challenges a
lot of joint pain and I'd actually just
got diagnosed with Lyme disease so I'm
kind of stepping into that similar so I
kind of understand the severe fatigue
where I'm fairly working 10 to 15 hours
and I'm beat
so she's she deals with some serious
pain issues mm-hmm okay
that's sad okay cuz really what did
Masters between the two households
somehow we got to find $72,000 because
otherwise they're going to take their
tax returns and their Social Security
until they get their money okay so they
would garnish my dad's check I'll tell
you everything yeah okay
it's a federally insured student loan
which gives them access to anything
that's federal only nothing else can get
at it but that can get at it
ha so I'm not gonna panic but you know
between the two of you you need to sit
down and do a budget and start putting a
thousand dollars a month on this thing
and then soon after you guys get your
husband's student loan debt cleared up
then and only then do you put extra
money on this but if you get a little
bit started get $1,000 a month start on
if they're not gonna do anything at that
point if you can get some kind of a
payment plan working with them and
thousand dollars a month will take care
of it you put in five hundred they put
in five hundred and your dad's just
gonna work more and he's not retiring in
65 okay
if 72 thousand dollars and dad and no
money and no assets and so he's gonna be
working more and you and your husband
are gonna be doing everything you can
get your income up and you can put in
five hundred bucks a month if you want
and then but no more until you get your
house in order when you get your house
in order then you're in a position to do
charity and that's what this is is
charity okay can I ask you a question if
I if I take over my my home we take over
the student loan payments just a
thousand dollars and my dad still
retires at 65 what they could still take
his checks or no that's as long as we're
for paint making the regular payments
they can't touch is Social Security
if you make a deal with them and pay the
payment that is the deal they're not
going to do that okay that's not that
doesn't work it doesn't work you guys
don't have enough money to do that you
just took on $100,000 plus and that with
your household income and you are
telling me you're a fatigued with Lyme
disease mm-hmm that doesn't work he
needs to keep working selling the house
just not wise at all no it's not it's
not because here's the deal if god
forbid your parents were to pass away
the loan is gone
mm-hmm and so I'm just cold hard facts
in here and there's a lot of feelings
and a lot of things you won't take care
of mom and dad but you know you don't
make $300,000 a year and you're not
worth two million dollars if you did and
you were I tell you to write a check and
uh that's fine pay it off I got no issue
with that I'm not mad about this but you
just you guys have your household to
watch over first and frankly your
parents have done a crummy job in the
last 12 years 12 freaking years and they
didn't take care of $40,000 and dad
they've done a crummy job and so you
know they really have and yeah I
understand they had some setbacks oh
they had some things happen I've had
things happened to me but 12 freaking
years for 40 grand and didn't pay a dime
on it not a dime
not once and so yeah he's working he's
working a while longer
won't hurt him and be good for him I
know he's 65 I'm 57 will work it's okay
you got 72 thousand dollars in debt work
and you guys get your budget tighten it
up and jump in there and help I'm I'm
with you on that part of it this is the
Dave Ramsey show